okay let's get started I was going to
say how pleased I was to see all of you
but the lights are in my eyes I really
can't see very well but welcome to the
2013 Gruber science fellowship lecture
for those of you who might not know me
I'm Carl Hashimoto i'm professor of cell
biology at the Medical School and
administrator of the Gruber science
fellowship at the graduate school the
dean of the graduate school tomm Pollard
unfortunately could not be here so I'm
filling in for him as best as i can so i
just want to say a few words about the
Gruber science fellowship it was
established in 2011 with what Dean
Pollard characterized as a breathtaking
gift from Patricia and Peter Gruber for
the support of students pursuing
doctoral studies in the basic sciences
we have close to 70 Gruber science
fellows now and come December September
we're going to have 22 new Fellows and
as Dean Potter said 100 years from now
when surely none of us are going to be
stomping on this earth they're going to
be Gruber science fellows running around
here pushing back the frontiers of
science which I think vividly evokes the
long-term impact of the goobers gift I'm
very pleased to say that Patricia Gruber
is here with us today Pat would you mind
standing up so everyone could see you
everyone please
thanks Pat so to introduce our
distinguished lecturer we have called
upon the services of one of the most
distinguished scientists at Yale
sterling professor of molecular
biophysics and biochemistry and 2009
Nobel laureate in chemistry Tom Stites
Tom
Oh little what light well it's a great
pleasure to be able to introduce Bruce
Albert's Bruce was an undergraduate at
Harvard and then a graduate student in
biophysics and and we overlapped for a
couple years at Harvard so that's where
I first got to know Bruce when he was
working in the laboratory of Paul DoDEA
would guess not very many of you are
familiar with Paul Dodi he then went off
to to Geneva in those days you do a
one-year postdoc he did a terrific lab
at Alfred dis years and then went to
Princeton where he started his
independent lab for 10 years at
Princeton and then after Princeton he
moved to ucsf where he sort of located
there he keeps yeah I think he has a
house there but he migrates around the
world and in recent decades if I were to
give a list of all the awards and prizes
and honors and committees and things
that he's been on we be here for the
next hour but importantly he's been he
was the president of the National
Academy of Sciences from 93 to 2005 and
he's currently for the last five year
been the editor of science but I want to
say a couple things about the research
that I know that he's done that are that
has affected my research and he started
out working on DNA replication when he
became independent and discovered
something called single-strand DNA
binding protein and and then started
working on the process of replication
which I have to say is something that my
lab has now been working on for the last
couple of decades as well but but he's
been fine he found the proteins many of
the protein
and participate in figure out how they
work on and what I one of the things I
really found wonderful is his his
trombone model you know it's always good
to have a good name for something these
days everything's the XYZ protein which
interacts with the QX our protein and I
have no idea what it's about but the
trombone model was to try and explain
how the the replication system the
polymerase can simultaneously go on both
strands of DNA because the synthesis
only goes in one direction but the DNA
of course is going in opposite
directions so the idea is that the
what's called the lagging strand loops
around and the synthesis goes on in the
lagging strand and that loop gets
smaller and then it jumps to the next
loop and it gets bigger so it's going in
and out and so we were just discussing
this you sort of think you read
something in a textbook you know
everything but actually there's always
just one more question and so we're
trying to ourselves figure out more
details about how this hall happens he
he joined with others to write many
versions or editions of the molecular
biology of the cell a very heavy
textbook I have to say it's got
everything you ever wanted to know in it
and and he's been very important in
promoting promoting science and
particularly science education I think
that's what we're going to hear some
about today that once you teach science
in as a query rather than the list of
facts who cares about just listing those
facts you want to be able to answer your
questions and and I think that's what he
promotes very effectively in his
thoughts about education so his his
title of his
talk is biology past and biology future
where have we been and where are we
going I always wonder where I'm going to
have to say so Bruce well thank you very
much it's a pleasure to be here I'm
sorry my friend Tom Pollard can't be
here but using smile hometown San
Francisco at a Deans meeting but I will
talk just keep your eyes open i have two
slides with his name on it and be sure
you tell him that i did that i could
remember grading Tom stites's and Joan
sites as exam papers in graduate school
so we go back a long way I'm gonna talk
about some of the things that Tom in
Urdu CEO he gave me a great introduction
because i'm going to start a little bit
with talking about something things that
i worked on which did in order to make a
general point about biology which is a
central role of protein machines in life
something we had no idea of when Tom and
I were in graduate school up I'll then
talk about the enormous amount that we
don't know as llama I were just
discussing unfortunately textbooks make
you think that we know everything
because we write about we don't what we
know but there's so much we don't know
and somehow we have to do a better job
as textbook writers and making that
clear and we're hoping in our sixth
edition which we're the middle of we
will do that I'll talk about something
that we also learned it when you're thin
last edition every time we write
addition we learn new things and this
idea of spatial organization inside
cells where everything's in the exact
position the cell is nothing like a test
tube then going off topic a little bit
since I just came back from a major trip
I don't tell you about my life is a
science envoy very briefly at the end
so I was a high school student when this
picture was taken Watson and Crick 1953
made their famous prediction of how
heredity worked based on the structure
of DNA double helical structure of DNA
Watson was only 25 years old I use it to
emphasize the importance of encouraging
young scientists to do their own thing
one of the very important features of
the u.s. of scientific systems that made
it has made it so successful now the
fact is although Watson and Crick oh
really solved the mystery they knew
nothing about the machinery then able to
DNA sequence to be copied from one
generation to the next and the next
breakthrough just as i was in college
was a discovery of this enzyme called
DNA polymerase at tom works on and many
other people work on an amazing enzyme
it that will copy the DNA sequences in a
DNA single-strand by adding one
nucleotide a time based on the base
pairing rules that Watson and Crick head
discovered and this is just the basic
reaction from our textbook the chain
grows one unit at a time from the three
prime and only the DNA premise only goes
in one direction a very important point
as Tom mentioned and the energy for
incorporation making this work comes
from the fact that the oxy driving
nucleoside triphosphate is hydrolyzed
every time you add a new monomer those
two red phosphates leave so this is
where I started my own independent work
1960 is a graduate student and we all
assumed not only me but a single enzyme
alone replicated DNA and the problem was
of course that would only work on a DNA
single-strand and the watson-crick
showed that DNA was double helical
inside the cell and moreover it only
went in one direction is tom was
pointing out and yet this two strands is
Watson and Crick discovered our
antiparallel go opposite directions so I
had a very missable career as a graduate
student at Harvard have you heard of
Harvard
me and many others were inspired by this
theoretical success of watson-crick to
make up theories about how everything
works in biology and i wrote a term
paper for my first year graduate course
about how DNA polymerase might be able
to start his DNA synthesis on a
chromosome even though da was double
helical and I got an a-plus on this
paper so I thought it must be right so I
then spent years trying to see if my
theory was right that was my least the
first part of my graduate career of
course it wasn't right there were many
no answers did not surprise anyone I did
not add to the store of scientific
knowledge nevertheless after five years
my professor thought I had written up
enough done enough experiments and all I
had to do at Harvard was to go what I
thought was a pure formality go to for a
little oral discussion of my thesis with
a set of famous Harvard professors
nobody had ever failed at this stage
that in living memory so I had already
given up my apartment I had a wife and a
one-year-old child and my tickets to
Geneva were were bought for the next
week little did I know but I got a
wake-up call they didn't think I had
done enough they didn't believe what I
written my thesis I failed my exam this
allowed me to write a whole paper about
what you learn from failure and in fact
older people like your professors or me
have a certain wisdom because we failed
so often and people who are successful
learn from their failures so every time
you fail you can be a little bit excited
about the fact that you're about to
learn something up so the first thing I
learned from my failure was a crucial
role of strategy in science of course I
also learned that theoretical biology
usually doesn't work because the cells
are too complicated but having a good
strategy and scientific research is the
key to success there are a million times
more experiments you
can do especially now than you should do
and so science is all about creativity
and designing novel and effective
strategies so I did finally get my PhD
six months later I did more experiments
I could then go to Geneva Switzerland
and I suddenly discovered that the whole
hypothesis that I had been working under
was wrong work had been done in this
large bacterial virus bacteria 5c four
has a long double strand DNA chromosome
geneticist had done at Caltech had done
an extensive analysis of how many genes
area are there are in that bacteriophage
and roughly what each one did just to
remind you this is a virus that attaches
to the outer envelope of e.coli bacteria
then the tail grabs on and like a little
syringe that injects its DNA into the
cell and starts replicating don't I have
a second lesson went because I hadn't
read that work which had published in
1963 that proved that many different
proteins are needed to replicate DNA
addition to DNA polymerase that was a
genetics demonstration but I had only
been reading biochemical papers so my
lesson number two is before you do
anything in science you want to read
everything you can and make sure you're
building your strategy for research on
what other people already know so this
is what I spent a lot of my early career
on trying to solve a major mystery why
were there at least 74 genes that were
absolutely required for replication of
DNA when this virus injected his DNA in
the coli cell now because the Genesis
had no idea what these things did they
just gave them numbers 32 41 43 and so
on one of these a little later was shown
to be the t4 bacteriophage DNA
polymerase the gene 43 protein then
we're six mysterious proteins needed
so what in the world could they do
obviously DNA replication was much more
complicated than anyone had imagined so
after my one-year postdoc I went to
Princeton twenty-eight-year-old
everything we were all 28 years old as
assistant professors in those days and I
focused on using the genetics to purify
the purity each of those six unknown
proteins and I had the dream starting in
nineteen sixty 60 when I had all seven
proteins I could mix them together and
then suddenly we could replicate
double-stranded DNA in a test tube this
is a picture of my lab 1969 because
anybody recognized me no but nobody
could recognize me I can't either but
anyway I'm the one on the red shirt with
the suspenders and this is just the
slide meant to show that science can be
fun we had a lot of fun so I developed a
strategy as I said I learned from my
failure that you need a strategy and so
my first strategy was to develop a
affinity chromatography system that I
could use to isolate from bacteria
fashion victim cells all the proteins
had bound to DNA with the idea that some
of those mutant proteins might be among
them and took me actually six months or
so in Geneva Switzerland to develop the
method and then I went back to Princeton
and this is my first success finding out
that when I infected with a
bacteriophage of any kind there was this
large band as you see the blue arrow of
major protein was president but that
protein was missing whenever you
infected with a mutant in the gene
called 32 and that turned out to be the
first discovery of the single-stranded
DNA binding protein and
this is my favorite protein you got me
tenure at Princeton and what it does is
it straightens out that DNA
single-strand and holds it in a good
position with the bases exposed for the
DNA polymerase it binds cooperatively
along the back of the DNA single-strand
and the the fact is you could see this
really nicely in electron microscope is
a collaboration i did with scientists hi
odalys was electron microscope egg
harbor took a circa a single-stranded
DNA molecule when you don't have 32
protein on it it forms all these short
hair print he Lisi's and it's all balled
up in little knots like an RNA molecule
would be due to hairpin he disease of
imperfect base pairs but when you cover
it with 32 protein you get this long
extended form of the DNA and the
co-operative finding and binding is seen
by some some molecules getting all the
pertinent 32 protein molecules others
not getting them so this is how the gene
32 protein helps DNA polymerase it
straightens out the Strand and we could
show that the plume race moves much
faster if it's coated with you protein
and if it's not and the fact is that we
use this model system to discover a
whole series of different kinds of
proteins which later were shown to be
also present in all organisms including
humans in the human version of this
protein is so called our PA protein so
I'm skipping forward took us a long time
but by 1975 we had collected purified
preparations of all seven proteins when
we mix them together we have this
magical day where we could now replicate
a double helical DNA template something
that I've been trying to do since
nineteen sixty when I said that visible
I graduate the student experience and we
need all all seven proteins you leave
out any one we didn't get
replication now the fact is why do you
do this the reason why you do is so what
you have a purified system with this
pure DNA and pure proteins and now you
can do chemistry you could leave out one
in protein or only have a mixture of a
couple proteins and see work your way
forward to what each of those proteins
do and I'm not going to go through that
but that's what we did it took us six
more years us being graduate students
the lab and this is one example the gene
43 protein turned out perform a sliding
clamp for the DNA polymerase which
allows the DNA polymerase to move for
hundreds of thousands of nucleotides
without dissociating now this when Tom
and I were in graduate school we I was
in a chemistry department we all knew my
professor was a physical chemist we all
know the enormous rap kidda T of
collisions and so we all thought that
that cell was a test like a test tube
with a very concentrated mixture of
proteins and small molecules in it
because of the rapid motions you didn't
need any organization it just the things
would collide in in react and so we view
DNA replication is the DNA plumber is
coming in binding to 3 PI and adding one
nucleotide falling off second DNA put
mine is coming in adding the next
nucleotide falling off and so on but it
turns out life doesn't work like this
the cell is nothing like a test tube and
everything is organized and the sliding
clamp that I talking about through the
work of Michael Donnell and then his
collaboration with John Korean was shown
to be a ring a donut we actually had a
graduate student working on this and we
missed it and working in the equalized
system Mike O'Donnell figured this out
so it's a it's a very simple mechanism
the ring is sliding along with DNA in
the day I Primera's whole held to the
DNA by this ring like a tether and the
DNA pretty much moves along and can't
get off the DNA keeps on working for
hundreds of thousands of nucleotides and
this is the way
the replication fork looks in two
dimensions the top strand is the leading
strand where the day implements could go
forever so it has some horrible defect
or something but basically go for
millions of nucleotides tethered to its
ring and as was said by Tom the other
one's got to go backwards and that means
that the DNA in a lagging strand has
made as a series of short pieces that
are stitched together in the end these
so called Okazaki pieces now if anybody
had told us this when I we were graduate
students we were said this is ridiculous
this person should be thrown out of
science you cannot never imagined that
you can make one strand as a series of
short fragments it would be a mess with
in fact that's how it works so this is
then the trombone revelation I was
giving a talk just like this somewhere
in Michigan or somewhere all of a sudden
I got this idea that this is crazy that
lagging strand DNA polymerase must be
used over and over again I can fact show
that by manipulating my experimental
system and indeed that's the case so the
fact is that that other lagging strand
is folded up around so that this
trombone slide goes in and out no you
know as each piece is made about once
per second so we now know that the same
mechanism is used to replicate DNA
everywhere however as you get to
bacteria yeast humans it gets more
complicated in a sense that each protein
has multiple subunits is controlled by
phosphorylation all kinds of stuff so so
this was a very useful way working in t4
and others in bacteria to really work
out the meccans was a shortcut to
understanding humans a very important
point today when professors feel pushed
by Grant committees to work on human
cells and a major lesson we learned is
that almost every process in the cell is
ruined by a complex of 10 or more
proteins that work as a protein machine
that replication machinery so like a
sewing machine to operate a machine that
you know about your experience you have
to have a series of parts and you have
to have directed motion which is
generally driven by electricity the
directed moment motion is also need for
protein machines the much tinier than
the ones you know make us able to talk
and listen to each other those are
different i ordered protein conformation
change is driven by bound ATP or gtp
hydrolysis in general and I'm going to
all this is all this up to show you this
movie that was made at Cold Spring
Harbor in the celebration of the 50th
anniversary of the 1953 DNA discovery so
it's a wonderful illustration not only
of how DNA replication works but how
life works and that's why I'm showing it
really for the latter reason of course
it's my favorite movie because we worked
on this for so many years without
understanding anything and then funny
this great aha understanding came from
from the work of many people in science
and that's why it's such a privilege to
be a scientist so let's see if we can
make this work using computer animation
based on molecular research we are able
to picture how DNA is replicated in
living cells you are looking at an
assembly line of miniature biochemical
machines that are pulling apart the DNA
double helix and cranking out a copy of
each strand the DNA to be copied enters
the production line from bottom left the
whirling blue molecular machine is
called a helicase it spins the DNA as
fast as a jet engine as it unwinds the
double helix into two strands one strand
is copied continuously and can be seen
spooling off to the right things are not
so simple for the other strand because
it must be copied backwards it is drawn
out repeatedly in loops and copied one
section at a time the end result is too
new
DNA molecules this is the trombone slide
and actually so some personal some
personal lessons learned I learned a lot
first of all if you work out a mystery
that nobody understands you'll make a
major contribution because that
mysteries like like liable to illuminate
many other things and of course
understanding how DNA replicates is
related to many other issues in biology
secondly as I intimate their remarkable
homologies between living things
therefore the shortest course to
understanding human cells even though
that's all you want to understand is to
use model organisms wherever possible
pleased to see people using Drosophila
worms all kinds of things and we have to
make the politicians and people who are
trying to today guide science
inadvisable ways understand that we need
to know things that we're not going to
be able to solve major human problems
without understanding much more about
biology through work with non-human
cells and finally of course we learned
that nearly all cell processes will be
based on elegant mechanisms too hard to
predict now there's lots of young
students here important challenge for
the next generation of cell biologists
biochemist is attaining the information
needed to accurately describe the
mechanism of every type of protein
machine in a Cell now we know that the
thousands of protein machines we know
many of their parts but we don't know
how most of them work tom has done a
beautiful job with others on
understanding the ribosome as a protein
machine but there's so many protein
machines that we don't understand and
these will have to be reconstituted to
the same way we did with DNA replication
we'll have to really do the hard
chemistry to make sure we understand how
they work and there's a lot to do a
tremendous number of important
challenges
I'm not going to shift to not where I
learned from my own research but what I
learned from writing this textbook which
seems to go on forever we started in
1978 these are the first four editions
this is the original set of authors
walking across Abbey Road the guy at the
back is Jim Watson who had the brilliant
idea he was no longer 25 of course same
Jim Watson had a brilliant idea that in
1978 was the time to start bringing
together a field called cell biology
with the field called molecular biology
and biochemistry well this is the
release of the last edition the fifth
edition we finally had some fun for a
change there's a lot of hard work
somebody arranged for us to be flown
down to Antarctica in the c-130 hercules
by the Chilean Air Force and here i am
presenting launching our book in january
2008 at the chilean air force base the
general had set up a podium and i gave a
little speech and i gave him a book and
then he ate read another speech that
somebody had written for him and he was
wondering what the heck was going on but
fortunately there was a young doctor at
the base versus was summer but he was
going to face a long dark winter and he
grabbed the book immediately he during
the winter he was going to read the book
and it didn't read this is what it's
like to write a textbook our textbook
was successful because we all worked on
everybody else's chapters it took us a
total of more than 365 12-hour days
working together to produce the first
edition and in this case this is all
before word processing this is the first
draft of the development chapter with my
Julian Lewis the pen is my writing on
top of the glue pen is my writing and I
don't know who that is somebody else
right on top of us I have so many pages
like this this is why it took so long so
this is all way of saying that we learn
a lot from
we learn a lot from teaching I'm a big
fan of teaching as a way of learning and
also writing textbooks and the the last
edition of the book we finally came to
recognize that life is incredibly
complicated positive and negative
feedback loops underline nearly all cell
chemistry creating complex networks of
interactions that will require new
mathematical computational methods to
decipher I'll talk a little bit about
that and secondly we recognize that
extensive sets of scaffold proteins
produce biochemical sub compartments in
the cell without requiring a membrane so
this is how all biology works when I was
a student we drew a goes to B goes to C
goes to D goes to E well that's right
but what was left out with all these
control mechanisms that make it possible
to make these you reactions really work
in a cell and feed-forward feedback all
kinds of mechanisms that make
understanding what any set of reactions
really means incredibly difficult and
i'll use a Tom Pollard example the actin
cytoskeleton which this is a figure from
our textbook which is a vast
oversimplification of all the proteins
that modulate the behavior of the actin
cytoskeleton the main actin filament a
very abundant long filament in cells is
in the middle and coming out off of it
are all kinds of arrows for proteins
that bind to it and modify its behavior
coming at the bottom off the bottom of
slide is a famous protein myosin that
hydrolyzes ATP and moves filaments at
the top you have left you have the
protein form and that nucleates the
formation of actin from the plus n and
various bundles you have all kinds of
other proteins that breakup filaments
like cofilin at any rate this is a very
complex set of interactions this is
another figure from our textbook about
just the yeast cytoskeleton has all
these interactions how could we make
sense of all these protein interactions
even when we know everything the human
mind can't make sense of it so even when
we have a complete list of all the
molecules protein machines and molecular
interactions in a Cell we will not be
able to understand it instead life
reflects what are called emergent
properties that result from very complex
networks of interactions and this is why
we need a lot of new ways of thinking
about how to deal with this complexity
so we'll need mathematical computational
models to decipher the systems on it
give you one example again based on
actin so one thing we could do we have
very fast modern computers that make
possible individual molecule based
simulations so-called agent-based
modeling you can make that tens of
thousands of molecules simultaneously
diffuse randomly and react in a virtual
virtual space you set up rules when they
bump into each other by random motion
gets so closer than a former complex and
so on you can see mate the positions of
all the molecules in steps of micro two
milliseconds and after billions of such
cycles which could take days you can see
what happens when you mix these things
together and if the emergent properties
observe for the whole system of
molecules closely resembles in the cell
then one can hope to use the model to
drive new experiments and make sure you
actually understand mechanisms so to use
such models require a large amount of
quantitative data you really have to
know all the molecules that you're
dealing with you which ones bind to
which you very importantly have to know
rate in the equilibrium constants for
forming each partner otherwise there's
too many variables and of course you
have to know how this same set of
molecules behave in a reconstituted in
vitro system that is a model system that
you could then go back and forth with to
try to make sure your model accounts for
the facts and of course you also want to
know that
that vitro system mimics what happens in
living cells so for this reason you have
to start with model systems that are
much simpler than the entire actin
cytoskeleton to model actin choosing
those were extensive biochemical work is
being done in this example of the
affection of cells by listener bacteria
mysterio bacterium provides a model for
actin mediated movement of intracellular
vesicles because this bacteria it comes
into the selgeh send us a toast then
hijacks the system that normally moves
small vesicles inside a eukaryotic cell
and performs an action tail that moves
the bacterium around propelling it even
from cell to cell so it doesn't get
exposed to the immune system and so many
people I have contributed to
understanding this model of listeria and
in particular marie france Carly and
France worked out an in vitro system
similar to the vitro system I described
for DNA replication but this is vitro
system for moving a bacterium in the
bacterium is replaced by a polystyrene
bead plus five purified proteins and
secondly and this is where yell comes in
nearly all the rate constant affinities
if the protein is set have been
determined by Tom Pollard in his
co-working was in USA actually he was at
Hopkins when he did much of this work
but you could take credit so here's what
happens when you make such a model the
actual bacteria is on the left the the
model and the computer is on the right
you see the speed of motion the
jerkiness of the motion and many other
parameters look right in the next slides
just a higher resolution view of that in
this example the yellow actin is the
activeness is polymerized with ATP bound
after is polymerized the ad tightly
bound ATP is hydrolyzed to ADP and
that's the red actin and they the ADP
actin is then cut by this protein
cofilin one of the five proteins and
assess set so the tail disappears
but as you see this is a really a
helpful way of sort of dissecting what
all these biochemical facts mean now of
course the next step is to take a next
most complicated system and try to
understand more and more parts of the
actin cytoskeleton in this way of course
it's a field of computational biology
that has many different approaches to
trying to solve such complex issues and
there's a set of review articles in
science magazine you want to just start
with with the burning straightforward
introduction to the field so there's a
hell heck of a lot less and left to do
in this field enormous challenge to is
why engineers mathematicians physicists
are badly needed to work closely with
biologists here up the second topic i'm
going to talk about is scaffold proteins
when we were writing our textbook for
the first three or so editions we made
the statement which we thought was
correct at the time that the way you can
speed up reactions in a Cell is to make
a membrane-bound vesicle like a lysosome
or peroxisome and concentrate two
proteins that work together in that
space now you so 10 times more
concentrated in that space they'll react
the collide 10 times more rapidly and so
on that that's true but that's probably
why we have peroxisomes but it's only
one of mechanism to do that it turns out
the standard way of doing that doesn't
involve a membrane involves something
called a scaffold protein which is a
vastly under-researched area many things
need to be done here but basically the
idea is shown in this little cartoon
from our textbook that by having a
flexible protein that binds protein in
arm RNA molecules you combine them to a
limited space you put them in you can
put them in a specialized part of the
cell which is also what happens and you
can speed up the reaction because of
course they will react much more polite
much more
rapid even they would otherwise and the
prototype example again is from Tom
Pollard the way that Foreman catalyzes
act in piraeus the former is one of
those actin binding proteins that causes
actin filaments to polymerize is at the
top left of that original diagram I
showed and the former is a red molecule
and the blue thing here is the actin
filament growing in the upward direction
direction and what was discovered by
measuring rate constants you have to do
chemistry is that the actin filaments
row at rates that are faster than
diffusion controlled that is faster than
the rate of collision of an actin
molecule with the plus end if there's
nothing else going on but of course
there is something else going on that
was what was discovered the this Foreman
has a whisker of scaffold that forms a
binding site for the actin in a loading
zone so that the disclosure of the actin
molecules with the plus and are much
more rapid than they would be otherwise
so the filament can grow much more
efficiently than it would otherwise more
complex scaffolds were reviewed in
science magazine is review by window
limb but what life is really like is
this cartoon from another review which
shows the biochemical space underneath
the synapse highly specialized space
under synapse scaffold proteins in
complex ways that we don't understand
yet needs a lot more biochemistry or
creating a unique biochemical
compartment underneath the synapse and
this is sort of a general theme of how
cells are organized and so basically a
cell is nothing like a test two cells
are not only putting things in specific
places inside themselves but those
places changed in response to cell
signaling this is just an example you
put a phosphate on you put a lipid on
you put a ubiquitin on proteins to move
into different places depending on the
state of the cell and we published a
nice special issue on spatial cell
biology
and this series of articles even shows a
vehicle by Lucy Shapiro and colleagues
that bacteria also do the same thing
even bacteria placed their proteins in
specific places to enable them to be
effective living cells so my conclusion
is that it will probably take most of
this century to gain a true
understanding of how cells and organisms
work much more biochemistry will be
needed in purified systems that
reconstitute that because it through the
biology like the replication system like
the system that move the bacteria in
action mediated way many more of those
systems will need to be established we
need many more biochemists it's a fuel
that's been neglected in recent years
we're also going to need new qualitative
methods for analyzing and understanding
the enormous complexity of life's
chemistry so what I always tell people
is that the first edition of our
textbook we had this statement that i
think is now wrong that as we learn more
we're bound to illuminate the incredible
underlying simplicity of living systems
and in fact they're not simple at all we
couldn't exist without this incredibly
elaborate chemistry that we don't really
know how to analyze yet I mean just
because we know all the parts you know
the big Evans this now you cat lying all
the G kettling all the genes all the
proteins all the RNA molecules we could
see that from what we know already that
that is far from being enough to reach
any understanding of how life works and
so we're going to need to have new
concentrated efforts you know for
example how can we expect to understand
a human cell if we can't really
understand even the simplest bacteria
there's a bacteria called mycoplasma it
has only 500 genes
500 genes 500 RNA and protein molecules
we don't really understand that so you
know why why don't we have a major
concentrated effort to get a lot of
people to work together on a mycoplasma
using both biochemistry and mathematical
modeling so we can actually gain the
tools we're going to need to jump to
more complicated systems you know
there's a under emphasis on this
fundamental knowledge that we need in
order to move forward so in summary
where has biology been in the past 50
years tremendous advances have been made
in our understanding of the molecular
basis of life driven largely by the
development of powerful new techniques I
mean the the cost of DNA sequencing I I
chaired the first committee in 1987 that
recommended a human genome project at
that time the cost of DNA sequencing was
five dollars per base pair we
recommended and that we not start
large-scale sequencing of DNA until we
can get the costs below 50 cents per
base pair the cost is now about a
millionth of what it was when we wrote
that report so that this is an example
of how science feeds on science the more
you know the more you can create new
powerful methods the faster science can
go but you know we're not yet done but
we can see the way to the end of a
remarkable descriptive phase in cell
biology since all the molecular
structures and pathways can now be
deciphered all those will still require
a lot of hard work but where's biology
going because life lifes chemistry is so
complex by far the most of us saying
chemistry known we now sort of realize
that most of the most interesting
attributes of life are do these so
called emergent properties properties of
stem from very complicated networks of
chemical interactions whose consequences
cannot be deciphered from the details of
a few
individual parts alone so we're going to
need innovative new methods and
approaches before you can claim to
understand even the simplest living
cells so so so there's a tremendous
amount left to do in in the sixth
edition of our textbook we're going to
try to do two things that we fail to do
in the previous editions one is we can
try to make it smaller it's too big and
where we know it's just impossible for
students can't get your mind around but
but secondly we're going to try to add
the examples of what we don't know
because students I'm just we know we're
knowing your students that they get
inside nearby reading is a textbook that
we know everything there's nothing left
for them to do which is just the
opposite of what it's true i would
estimate we know five percent about what
we need to know about cells something
like that and the second thing we do
we're going to have a new chapter on how
we deal with complexity to make students
in biology aware that that many of them
should think about learning some
mathematics and computational skills to
help us with these incredibly difficult
challenges so now I'm going to shift
gears completely to a final topic which
is a science diplomacy in 2009 I
suddenly got a call from the White House
saying they would like me to be a
science envoy what in the worlds of
science envoy well first of all I
learned very quickly it's an unpaid job
second of all it was an idea hatched by
Obama's talk in Cairo in June of 2009
how are we going to start a new
relationship with the Muslim world we at
Gulf a very bad start after 2001 and so
one of the proposals that he said that
he will report point science envoys to
muslim-majority nations and they had
chosen me to be the science of envoy
for India and Pakistan they chose to
other people the user hunie who's who's
from Algeria and anyway yeah the other
two people they chose were obviously
from Muslim countries knew the area I
had never even thought about Indonesia
and I'm born in Chicago those guys were
born in in that region so well if I went
now in the end I they never were able to
get me to Pakistan every time I was
about to go CIA officer shot somebody in
a motorcycle or something and they
couldn't protect me because I be
official representation so I finally did
my pakistan duties by meeting a whole
bunch of people and dubai it was just
not not perfect by any means and by by
giving talks by skype but i have spent a
lot of time in indonesia and about to go
for the fifth time this summer because
even though my appointments over we're
still trying to see if we can make
science diplomacy work so so this is
indonesia its first time i went i flew
from jakarta over way over to the right
side of Indonesia's further than across
the United States 250 million people
more than ten thousand islands and
before we went we said we Americans are
always going everywhere and they're
promising everything and nothing ever
happens so let's make sure that
something happens associated with this
visit and so we got the State
Department's commit to supporting a
event called frontiers of science a kind
of networking between the future leaders
of science in the United States and
other countries that have been pioneered
by the national academy of sciences
initiative with China but also still
going on with many other countries India
Germany so on and so the first
thing I want to show you is this a
result of this science envoy business is
the picture taken at the first annual
fortunate of science meeting and the
fellow in the front and the blue shirt
is my close colleague the president of
the Indonesian Science Academy Sangha
Mizuki was instrumental in getting this
fall to work and so it's run by his
Academy in our Academy they select 35 or
40 people on each side the model is that
six those people on each side are the
organizing committee and they determine
what's on for three days and gives young
people an experience of organizing in
and creating something that's their own
these are sort of like a mixer because
there's new grant opportunities from the
US the NSF pure program in the NIH peer
program program so after the meeting
they could apply to be partners and get
research collaboration money my first
visit I met with the president of it in
an issue in deneva but President
Yudhoyono and he said he had been a
young general in the army in Kansas yet
a young son and that son had a very good
science teacher who did what we call
inquiry science teaching you know they
were solving problems and he wanted this
kind of inquiry science teacher for
Indonesia so we've been trying to help
by helping send our best science
teachers over to Indonesia to run
workshops for their lead science
teachers and took this picture way in
the back in the middle are two
outstanding teacher leaders from the
United States who ran several workshops
for the Indonesians of course it's going
to take continuing efforts there so two
main themes of science diplomacy our
first promoting ties with us scientists
that helped to strengthen science and
the influence of scientists and other
nations we want in an Asian scientists
to have influence with their government
so the government makes good decisions
about you know environmental issues
health issues all kinds of issues and
these ties also build long-lasting
personal relationships of trust and
understanding across borders and since
we're choosing the very best
thirty-five-year-old scientists in both
countries we expect them to be future
leaders in both countries and therefore
help create good relationships between
Indonesia in the United States my first
experience with frontiers of science was
when I was present in the US National
Academy of Sciences and we did the we
had a meeting with the Chinese Academy
and we clocked up we decide we wanted to
do something like this and I went to one
of the first meetings and the leaders on
this scientific it was a meeting in
Beijing and I met the leader on the
Chinese side of the their delegation his
name is chen xue xue chin however you
want to say it a wonderful cancer
biologist for the last i think five or
so years he's been the Minister of
Health of China so so every time I go to
China we have a private dinner and it's
a great communication tool between our
two countries and that's the kind of
thing we're trying to establish much
more widely and the second theme is
helping to spread a type of inquiry
science teaching that empower citizens
and promotes democracy we want everybody
everywhere on the world to be able to
think like a scientist to look for
evidence to be critical of dogma and try
to help build a more rational world so
I'm going to end by telling you about my
most recent trip I somehow when you
start being a science diplomat even
though I'm not officially one anymore
I'm still doing it I'm still going to
Indonesia I'm going to the third
frontiers meeting next month I just
returned from a 23 day trip to india
egypt and sudan one of the things i did
was i attended the us-india frontiers of
science meeting it was in Agra
he was the picture taken a short while
ago actually of the Indian and American
scientists and then after that I went to
the Sudan I didn't really know where
Sudan was that's right south of right
south of Egypt this is the Nile floating
the Nile flows up upward at the top is
the Aswan Dam and Laura Lower Egypt so
it flows up the sea at Alexandria so
most of Egypt has not even shown but
much of the Nile shown here is in the
Sudan right in the middle there where
the is a meeting of the White Nile and
the Blue Nile the capital Sudan called
Khartoum and that's where I was right
that branch point if you could read it
but I don't have a pointer here's a
picture out a hotel window is this that
the hotel is right at the meeting of the
two now rivers one coming from Uganda
and one in one coming from Ethiopia and
then we're looking up towards Egypt many
thousands of miles away now what was I
doing there well there's a movement
coming out of Malaysia to help change
the nature of science education in the
Muslim world and I was there because
there was a workshop of being organized
the train teachers from that region
Sudan in other countries in North Africa
halted teaching active inquiry science
to children in their respective
countries and associated with that was a
workshop called the future of science
education I was the moderator the people
in the panel were from France UK Jordan
the guy from Jordan was former prime
minister and the Malaysian who's most
responsible for getting this whole
movement going in by the way i'm holding
a tablet i just picked up in in india
read about in my last issue of science
magazine because I'm and ending june
first so may thirty first our issues got
a special issue about what we learned in
india about using science and technology
to improve the livelihoods of poor
people and one of the things we
discovered is this so-called aakash
tablet which they are producing it will
plan to give to every school kid in
india a lot of people but basically the
fact is it it looks like a mini ipad the
next generation I think will be good
enough to use in the United States
coming in a year and it's only gonna
cost fifty dollars so I was quite
excited about destroying it to the
Sudanese but I'm also quite excited
about it for the United States so funny
we can maybe get to the point where our
resources get away from these very dull
textbooks that our children are plagued
with and raising all kinds of
opportunities so so so here's so there's
a three hour discussion with the
audience from SUNY and the Minister of
Education was there the woman I'm
talking to here and the funny thing is
that after I left but I got an email
with all these paid newspaper clippings
on the front page in many of the
newspapers was picture of me and I had
no idea what it was saying but but iono
else Ahmad who's a wonderful
mathematical biologists at UCSF native
languages arabic and so she said what
it's saying is that Bruce Albert's since
I gave a talk about inquiry science so I
can't give them any places you know we
don't want kids to memorize things we
want them to learn how to ask questions
solve problems think like a scientist we
want every kid to be able to do that and
so it says Bruce Albert says that the
Sudanese curriculum in science is
terrible
well I didn't even know what the kirkham
was but anyway but but the good part is
it it says also that the Education
Minister agrees with me so maybe I mean
maybe we have some effect but so this is
part of this big dream of making the
world more rational place the
international scientists collaborating
to try to help teachers teach
differently because it won't happen
without active involvement of scientists
in every nation and our next meeting in
fact is going to be in Indonesia as part
of my next trip another training session
for fruit for the the teachers in
Indonesia so so this is my favorite
quote and it gets to the whole purpose
of all this science diplomacy this
there's a wonderful book written by the
physicist Jacob burnofsky called science
and human values published in 1956
burnofsky flew over Hiroshima and
Nagasaki as a young man in the army got
incredibly depressed asking whether
science was really bad for the world or
was it could it be bad bad for the world
to have science so he spent ten years
reading and thinking he wrote this
magnificent book and his conclusion is
of course that science is good for the
world he said this a society of science
scientists is simple because it has a
directing purpose to explore the truth
nevertheless it has to solve the problem
of every society which is the final
compromise between the individual and
the group it must encourage a single
scientist to be independent and the body
of scientists to be tolerant from these
basic conditions was formed the prime
values there follow step-by-step a range
of values descent freedom of thought and
speech justice honor human dignity and
self-respect Sciences humanized our
values men have asked for freedom
justice and respect precisely as a
scientific spirit has spread among them
and really I think this is the major
focus for me of all this science
diplomacy to try to help not only
develop scientists everywhere
strengthening their ability to be
effective as scientists but
strengthening their ability to
their societies in very positive ways
like this so I'm just going to end with
my last special issue on science
education for science magazine just came
out the when i finish at the academy I i
was at UCSF very happy teaching students
and relaxing and I got a call from a
recruiting firm asking if I wanted to be
considered as for editorship of science
magazine and I said no I don't want no
more jobs so then then they I got a call
saying they wanted me to do it anyway
six months later but the critical thing
that made a difference that I can use it
to try to promote better science
education better education so I've tried
to do that we've had for special issues
on science education I'm very pleased
that we've been able to put up a website
with most of our science resources we've
had two years of prizes for the best
free science education websites called
spore the collections at the bottom
we've publishing still publishing the
winners of two years of contests for the
best inquiry-based college laboratories
things that can be used at Yale here
there's a in all these cases there's two
page article in science magazine plus in
this case all the instructions you need
to give that lab as electronic
supplement a new project I'm going to
keep working on as a volunteer science
in the classroom where were you trying
to prepare a science article every month
that's appropriate for meet the aim help
every student in the United States at
least have during their life read one
scientific article with the aim of
having they'll understand how science
works and what it is because that that's
what's really critical for enabling our
citizens to
value the judgments of science and be
able to understand what science is all
about and of course all of our special
issues including the last one up there
and you don't need to subscribe to
science because we wants teachers to use
this this is an open-access web web site
so the final conclusion my last slide is
it there many wonderfully exciting
challenges for young scientists I've
been talking to many of them today they
have so many so much energy and so much
interest in using science and one way or
the other to improve the world I just
urge all of you to be creative and
intellectually ambitious thank
happy to answer some questions we ask
that if you want to ask a question to
take a microphone we have several goober
fellows around with microphones so if
you want to ask a question please raise
your hand yeah so my question is
obviously something it's very important
for like science both and its present as
well as like future is how it is how its
funded what are your thoughts on how
science is currently funded what do you
think are like would be the best way to
to to fun science I'm sorry but I
couldn't hear I'm sure yeah yeah sorry
so I was just saying it's important for
both science presently as well as in the
future as how science is funded what do
you thought somehow science is currently
funded and how do you think how do you
think science should be funded haha so
we've been talking a lot about that
today I wrote I've been a reviewer every
cycle for something called the NIH
called the young innovator award for
people less than seven years out of the
PhD the important part about the young
innovator award said you to do something
risky different and you don't need any
preliminary data I wrote an editorial
till the first time I the first cycle
that they had forty five hundred
applicants and they gave something like
30 Awards so maybe it was 50 so I wrote
an editorial three years ago or so
saying the way to really you know help
science in the United States is to have
500 of those not 50 so that the common
way of thinking of young scientists is I
got to think of something that's risky
new and novel and right now of course as
you know the conservative system that's
created by scientific review panels is
forcing many young people to do the same
thing as their mentors after their
postdoctoral work so i would first of
all reserve a pot of money for the
starting at scientists and second of all
I try to use it to encourage the best
people to go in new direction
other things I've said here I think
we've got way too much emphasis or
misinterpretation of what Translational
Medicine means who does AAG be is a
wonderful scientists at Baylor she wrote
an editorial for science maybe two
months ago called the basics of
translation now she's an MD she does
beautiful work on rett syndrome terrible
disease children have and she got into
science because she wanted to do
something for these sign these toulon
she was dressing as a as a doctor but
she made the point that you know trying
to translate without basic
understandings of biology her analogy is
like trying to translate Shakespeare
with the first grade vocabulary it's a
wonderful editorial which I think the
leadership of NIH and many others should
be paying attention to too many young
scientists feel they have to work on
human cells to get funded and that's as
I implies is a very bad for for making
progress in the very thing that the NIH
wants to do which is solve human disease
so there are a lot of things that I
think we could do better and now that we
have this stagnant budget it should be
motivating us to think carefully about
how we spend our money so the answer to
your question is that you know we have a
lot to be proud of Indonesia for example
has very low science funding they have
no competitive Grants Program and one of
the things we're trying to do is help
them establish a competitive Grants
Program many other countries we just had
an editorial from Japan from me I'll
monocular just win the Nobel Prize
pointing out that young scientists
really don't have the opportunity in
Japan that they have in the United
States so the United States is good in
many ways we've encouraged young people
to be independent but love parts of our
system are not working right now and
hopefully we could straighten it out
before the we're trying to graduate
switch days well
I don't have to worry about it for
another eight years so by then we hope
to have it all fixed so regarding the
future of biology you mentioned that new
mathematical and computational tools are
going to be needed to help us understand
it's increasing complexity you also
mention that more biochemistry is going
to be needed to adequately parameterize
those models so a lot of the the most
useful quantitative tools we have now
came from like classical biochemistry
and so do you think like the hill
equation Michaela etc do you think that
that sort of classical period can inform
scientists moving forward and trying to
develop a new perspective what's this I
couldn't well the end of it what do you
what was the end of it um a part of
hearing that was what I mean so
basically like mckaela's mitten inhale
and hurt you know they they were
biochemist who got these parameters and
they also develop mathematical models
which are extremely useful now like the
bread and butter but those dated from
like the 1910s 1930s do you think that
there's something in that classical
period that we're missing now which can
help us move in the future specifically
because you mentioned how mathematical
models and also basic biochemistry is
going to be necessary moving forward
well that's right i mean basically you
need collaborations i don't think a
person could be good at everything i
spent all my life in a cold room purify
things we need more people to be
purified proteins incentive in vitro
sisters but and it'd be good if we could
train people to also be on the forefront
of the new kind of mathematics we aren't
even what kind of mathematics we need
nobody does but so so we need to get
talented people at that interface and
i'm not sure what the right but what I
do know is that physicists and
mathematicians and computer scientists
are very talented can waste a lot of
effort if they don't deeply understand
biology so you know either we have to
make sure that
we form partnerships that you know as I
said there are million more experiments
you should do then you you can do then
you should do and it's probably a
billion more computational teach you you
can't do then you should do so strategy
is everything and I think you know place
like Yale could could really have a you
know a regular process of getting people
together who have different skills and
trying to make sure that what people are
working on we have great computational
mathematical talents is closely informed
by the biology so you know it calls for
new kinds of post partnerships I'm not
sure that we can expect one person to be
able to do all that
so in your in your talk you mentioned
the genome project wants but you did not
mention the word genomics or proteomics
do you feel those projects are worthy
for young scientists to pursue so I did
not happen the microphones pretty fuzzy
do you did you do you understand the
question okay so yeah like yeah okay I
can I get there it's much clearer
without the microphone so why didn't I
mention genomics and proteomics in my
future because that's part of the that
was the first slide we have the ability
to describe and Tom sites will get the
structure of every one of the thirty
thousand persons in the human cell you
know we know how to do that and we're
doing it we're investing it but the
mistake we're making is we're not we're
thinking that data is knowledge data is
not understanding so we have to get
there people who are sort of hyping the
idea that we just collect enough data
enough you know RNA sequences protein
structures and so on that's going to
lead to our understanding and my major
point of this whole talk really is that
we need more than that the descriptive
part which is happening we don't need it
I don't need that encourage that it's
not enough we need to to deeply
understand and create new methods and
for example you know why isn't there a
powerful group of people gotten together
to try to understand bacteria like
Michael
I mean you need all kinds of skills you
need computational people you need
biochemist you need cell biologists you
demand you all you you know you we need
new methods and so if you can work out
that new methods and you know I think it
would be a major breakthrough if we
could really predict the behavior of a
cell with 500 gene products but but
we're that kind of work you know Lamar
Smith is in the newspapers now the head
of the Science Committee in a house by
saying every grant has to be justified
on what it's going to do for human
beings I mean this is you know this if
you had to do this you know how am I
going to explain what understanding
mycoplasma is going to do for human
beings it's going to do a lot for human
beings but it's going to be 50 years
from now and if we don't do that kind of
work we're never going to get there
because just cataloging proteins it's
not it's not enough we need new
innovative approaches and they have to
be work out in systems that are simpler
than the whole complex enormously
complex human cells with this de
staggering complexity yeah so you can
actually ask individually heat questions
to Bruce Albert's at the reception with
to which I welcome you it's in the
dining hall to your right as you exit
the auditorium pass the signs for the
restrooms so I like to thank you
you